i'm here with three individuals each of
whom are considered by many to be the
greatest of all time in each of their
respective disciplines
the greatest mma fighter of all time
george saint pierre
the greatest martial arts coach of all
time john donahue
and the greatest submission grappler of
all time
gordon ryan
so let me ask the first question
you guys didn't see the question no
preparation here what is the key to your
success each of you one thing or
multiple things that come to mind
john go first
[Laughter]
um
is it the rash guard
yes
[Laughter]
i like that you choose john right off
the bat you seem the most nervous please
inspire us to
give the right answer
for for me it's about um
finding a way to work
in a world where
most of the answers are already known
okay in any developed sport
by the time you enter that sport most of
the basic precepts the the
the major techniques that the major
mechanical understandings of the sport
are long since worked out
and so
in a highly developed world
the key to success
is to be able to identify
some area of the industry that you're in
which is currently undervalued
to do what the other people are not
doing
deeper than that you're you're
everyone has a view of okay these are
the
the main skills of the industry i work
in
at any given time
some set of skills
um
will always be somewhat undervalued
they're underappreciated by the people
in the game
you see that at any in any given
industry there are always trends
which
uh the nature of the industry over time
so
uh fashion trends
in the clothing industry you'll see at
any given time there's a a a general
wave of fashion which pushes most of the
people in the industry in a given
direction at a given time
what makes people stand out is the
ability to
look at the various possibilities out
there and say here is something which is
genuinely useful
but which is currently being underused
underutilized
and i want to bring that back in
and develop it
and because it's an inherently useful
product
it will be very very successful in its
initial applications against people who
aren't currently using it
um
if you can do this in whatever industry
you're in i believe you'll be highly
successful
so this implies both for actual specific
like techniques
and the also tactics as well in the case
of of jiu-jitsu so for example
in my sport leglocks have always been
around okay there's
no shortage of people you can look back
in history who are applying leg locks
nonetheless as in
across the industry
leglocks were undervalued and
under-appreciated there was a general
sense in which most of the leading
figures of the sport
for most of the history of the sport of
judas who tended to de-emphasize
leglocks and uh
when i looked at them i said there was
there was immense potential but it
wasn't being realized
and needed to be changed um
since then that
has more or less occurred now most
people coming into the sport understand
that leglocks are an important
aspect and they're no longer undervalued
if anything has gone too far the other
way and now perhaps they're a little
overvalued
um
and the uh this kind of uh fashion trend
exists in every industry
and
the job of anyone who wants to excel in
a given industry is to be able to
identify okay what are the things that
are currently out of fashion and
undervalued and then
look at what is their actual objective
value
and then work uh to to
to bring them back to the forefront so
john brought up fashion uh george is
wearing a really sexy shirt so
assuming that's not the reason is there
um
is there something that comes to mind as
the key to the success of your
incredible career well of course
everybody knows the famous sensor that
every athletes are saying oh it could be
genetic i was maybe gifted i had certain
predisposition i worked really hard
but i think
something that
people don't talk enough is when
everybody sometimes go right
i was never afraid to try to go left
and i felt many times
trying to do things that were not
uh
known to be things that would
bring me brought me success but i i i
tried it you know i was very often i was
the first of trying new things
and i felt many times but certain times
it gave me a certain advantage and um
for example
i was sometime fighting guys that had
much better wrestling background than
than me on paper and nobody before
that fought those guys never nobody had
there to try to
take them down because their wrestling
pedigree were so good and i didn't have
on paper like wrestling pedigree to take
these guys down in a fight
but
when everybody
tried to go right i was going left i i i
fought them in a different way and that
was
the blueprint to beat cert some of these
guys you know what i mean you know what
i mean so yeah so we'll actually talk
about a few fights where you did just
that this is fascinating
um but let me let's stay at the high
level so gordon
again sticking on fashion
may have compliments your
incredible badass hat trying to fit in
here
we should say we're in texas now so he's
uh
become a texan overnight uh so what is
there something you can speak to that
you would uh attribute to as the key to
your success yeah so first of all there
has to be a rule where you don't ask all
the same questions because
how am i supposed to compete with the
answer john just gave me that there's
nothing i can do that's going to top
that yeah um but uh
i think it's uh
there's many things but i think the
number one thing is just is john um when
i came in uh i was a blue belt and i was
beating brown and black belts in
competition already
but he really changed my way of thinking
about the sport i would just come in and
if something wasn't working i would just
do it harder and faster and more
aggressively and that just degenerated
me into degenerated into
me spastically knee sliding into cross
hashigarami against eddie cummings for
six months and then just getting heal
hooked repeatedly
and uh i'm like this is not working and
eddie like when i met him was like a
chubby librarian looking guy and i'm
like there's i'm like six two like a
jacked like 170. and i'm like there's no
way i'm losing to a guy who looks like
this but he just kept healing me so i
would just go harder and harder and it
wouldn't work and then john's like well
if you learned leglocks you might you
might have some more success and then i
was like yeah that probably makes sense
and uh from then on i kind of just
changed
the way i thought about the sport
instead of doing doing things harder i
would actually try to get better at
jiu-jitsu do you remember like a turning
point where
you became as opposed to being mediocre
not just in technique but an approach to
uh to great um i think it was somewhere
around brownbow level when i was
training consistently started training
full-time with john when i was purple
belt mid-level purple belt
and towards the end of my brown belt uh
days i was beating up like legitimate
like adccc champions in the gym
so i think like
brown to black belt was a big thing for
me and then when i won my first ebi and
i was i submitted yuri who won abcc and
i beat roostam um so i think that was
like my turning point as a competitor
but i think i started to to reach world
level a little bit before that i think
somewhere around brown about mid-level
to late level brown belt so is some of
that mental like
it was there a moment when you like
after a training session
you realized
i could actually do this
like i could be at the top of the world
like world class the critical moment for
me was when uh i think it was right
right when i got my black belt maybe a
few months before i got my black belt uh
we had a former adccc champion come into
the gym and uh we did a hard round
together and i think i submitted them
like four or five times and uh knowing
who i was i never won anything up until
that point and i was like okay like if
this is like one of the best guys in the
world and i could submit him multiple
times around i think that this is like
something that i actually could do
professionally and make a make a career
out of this
okay so the actual performance was the
like you didn't need to uh believe
before you could perform like a lot of
olympic gold medalists
they
they have to believe before they can
perform because like
they're getting their ass kicked for a
long long long time yeah i think but the
best way for me to believe in something
is to have repeated success doing it
against high level guys like i'm not
gonna just believe i can do a double leg
if i can't a double egg on anybody um so
for me
the the belief came from the repeated
success in the gym
yeah but to get to the point where
you're submitting somebody like yuri
samoa is like one of the greatest
grapplers ever
it's like a long journey
yeah but i i had the confidence i had
the belief in myself because of the
success that i had in the gym prior to
that got it to that event even and it's
one step at a time first it's the brown
bells not as the black belt it's world
class okay um george was there a turning
point for you when you you thought
like i can actually do this
yes i um
i always dreamed to become champion
but i think the turning point that there
was there was two turning point
and there were my two losses uh
first
my losses to matt use i went into that
fight
just
to not lose i i was not fighting to win
and it's after the fight when i watched
the
the replay of the fight i realized i was
like i was doing pretty well but during
the fight in my own mind
i was not seeing it that way i i thought
i was getting dominated by use like a
hundred percent but when i watched the
replay
i was like man i can i can beat this guy
i was beating him until i made that
stupid mistake so it was very
frustrating but but
that's what gave me the mentally the the
championship level mentality and then i
became a little bit overconfident
because i i start beating everybody
after that
and i start to believe the hype of
people when they look at me they were
like oh he's the new upping coming
superstar and he's going to be
unstoppable and
and then when i became champion i
i lost to to to matt to matt sarah
so
before i i believe
my first failure was because i had a
lack of confidence
and
and my second failure was i was because
i was overconfident so i think it's
there's a perfect uh
center of confidence i mean i mean it's
good to be confident
because john taught me like confidence
it's it's like money in your bank
account if you you can have all the
skills in the world right and and if
you're uh if you don't have the
confidence it's like you it's like you
can you can be a millionaire but you
don't have access to your bank account
so so it's that's a little bit the
analogy that john told me so that's how
i feel confidence plays for an athlete
but to be overconfident i think it's
always good to
to be aware to be afraid
of what can happen
so to have a perfect balance of
confidence and fear to me
that's what mentally gave me the edge to
become i believe successful in my sport
playing off that uh john gave me a
speech one time and he was like you have
to be able to
like flip a switch and turn it off where
like a guy like mayweather or someone
who goes out who's super confident
and he plays the character of someone
he's like no one can beat me i'm the
best that there ever was and that's it
um but if you look at me actually trains
very hard you can't you can't play the
persona of no one can beat me and have
it translate into your life and just
think that you're so good that you don't
have to do anything and no one can ever
beat you you have to be able to play
that public persona of no one could beat
me but then you have to actually do the
training to make that happen you can't
just you can't believe your own hype and
say say that you know i can just do
whatever i want no one's ever going to
beat me you'd be able to switch between
the persona and the actual athlete and
that made a big difference for me
it's tough because uh like you're
you dominate
such a large fraction of the world in in
grappling
and george too just the perfect
dominance after those two
um it's hard for the confidence not to
just
like how do you avoid the confidence not
becoming a thing that weighs you down
where you completely um
deludes your mind
um for me it's just well number one the
guys in the gym are so tough so
the guys and the
guys in the gym that i train with her
always like nipping at my butt and
always giving me new problems to solve
um and for me it's really just about
trying to learn new stuff over time um
so that keeps it interesting for me and
it's not really about
um
you know no one can beat me i don't have
to train i have to do it i can do
whatever i want uh it's more
what keeps me in the gym is more about
the fact that i'm learning new stuff all
the time and working on something new
and progressing to new levels at all
times it's not i don't just come in and
do the same thing over and over again
and uh that gets boring you just come in
and you don't learn anything new and you
just do the same stuff for years at a
time and okay okay this is boring but
when you have new stuff to work on and
new goals short-term and long-term goals
to reach then it makes it interesting
it's um for me it's a little bit like
gordon says is the fair because sometime
in the gym i even before when i was
competing i was i was getting my butt
kicked
but i don't care what happened in the
gym i mean it it hit my ego of course
because i'm a proud person i'm a
competitor even in the gym but it's not
a malicious competition
competition in between each other when
you fight you have to be malicious you
go there to hurt the guy
but it
it hit it hit me in terms of my pride
when i get
beat in a gym of course
but that fear
that
i don't want it to happen in public
especially not during a fight that what
keeps helping me keeps the balance
between confidence and and and and fear
you know what i mean it's kind of weird
it's a mix
it's a mixture of boat that
i believe
i to me it
helped me uh succeed to have the right
uh mindset to fight and i talked so much
[ __ ] that i'm like man if i lose this is
gonna be rough so yeah you put a lot of
i mean that's that's the hard thing to
do when you talk [ __ ] when you when you
play the heel
is so much to perform the pressure is
i mean you have to be good under
pressure it's the conor mcgregor thing